[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday August
10th Hank were in Western North Carolina
at the yetis family reunion that's why
we're walking through the woods I guess
it's also kind of our family reunion
since our parents are here too but
you're not here so it's not that much of
a family reunion incidentally everyone's
always like why does he keep doing this
why is he always doing this that's just
what I do it's one of my things Hank I'm
on the trail of the Yeti and I think I'm
getting close look it's a Yeti footprint
Hank I think I see the Yeti again there
she goes there she goes yeah we missed
her look Hank it's this tacular
sometimes I wonder when my experiences
would be like if I didn't mediate all of
them through a video camera Hank the
house in which we are staying has a lot
of bears there's a silhouette of a bear
that presumably means bears welcome here
which they are not there are bears and
easy-chairs
there's bears on the welcome sign
there's a bear clinging desperately to
this wooden pole there's a stuffed bear
in a little wicker chair little
Christmas ornament bears with no
Christmas tree there's even a bear on a
swing I can't help but think that all
this cute fetishizing of bears is making
the Bears mad and if there's one
distinct group of organisms I don't want
to anger its bears they'll be all like I
am NOT a little guy that swings in a
swing I am a huge 500-pound animal my
claws could tear out your heart I like
to eat berries lots of berries you don't
wanna mess with those guys Hank they can
eat berries like you read about Hank in
other news it looks like I'm going to be
eating a blender eyes happy meal while
waxing two of my legs or maybe if you're
kind two of my arms although on the
other hand do I want to have stubbly
arms I don't know I hate to be
completely honest there's no way I ever
thought that I was going to have to do
that punishment because I didn't think
that that many people would give money
to Daniel's campaign I thought it would
just be kind of funny and I could laugh
about it while I was comfortably eating
peeps and waxing a mere one of my limbs
but it turns out that I underestimated
the nerdfighters and let that be a
lesson to you everyone
never underestimate nerdfighters Hank
I've thought a lot about eating a
blender eyes too happy meal and every
time I think about it it makes me do
this so I'm looking forward to it but
anyway Hank I'm still happy to
my punishment can do something to
decrease worldsuck and hopefully
something to get Daniel elected I'd also
like to remind everyone that they have
until midnight tonight to give money to
Daniel's campaign and remember it's not
the amount of a contribution it's the
number of people who contribute also
it's the amount of the contribution by
the way Hank and going over the donor
list I couldn't help but know to glare
an absence you you've got till midnight
Hank get on it Hank I hope outside is
treating you as well as it's treating me
and I'll see you tomorrow no I'll see
you on Monday